hey everyone it's Mike from mfls and
welcome back to my channel in today's
video I'm going be talking about points
of control specifically the PO Shadow uh
tool that we've added into orderflows
Trader 8 which is the latest version of
orderflows Trader now just uh really
quick if you enjoy the channel enjoy the
content that I put out be sure to hit
the Subscribe button and as well as hit
that notification Bell so anytime I post
a new video now that we've got uh
orderflows Trader out and released you
know I'm trying to get videos out on how
to maximize the tools in your trading so
you know be sure to hit that
notification Bell so whenever I post a
new video you'll be notified of it all
right so you know in order flow right
specifically on the footprint chart uh
the point of control is the price level
in the bar with the most volume you know
every bar has a point of control and
sometimes it means something other times
it doesn't mean anything you know I mean
think about it right what is volume
right well volume is important in the
sense of where it appears in the bar you
know generally speaking you know volume
tends to be concentrated somewhere
towards the middle of the bar on on
average in normal bars but again there's
going to be instances where points of
control appear at certain areas of a bar
and you know once you start having those
point of controls appearing at certain
areas of the bar generally speaking the
next level of volume is going to appear
there as well so you're starting to get
clusters of volume appearing so you know
in our years of analysis uh we we've
determine that points of controls where
they land in a bar are important and to
make it useful to Traders what we've
done is we've added a tool on the
orderflows trader 8 called PLC Shadows
so let me just pull up the indicator
settings here real quick
and you're going to scroll down into the
PLC Shadows right here enable PLC
Shadows now the thing with uh the PLC
Shadows is it's really meant to be a
reversal indicator for for finding
potential reversals in the market
basically what's happening is um you
know Market's poking up into a new high
swing high or new swing low um you know
is sort of rotating around you know
heavy volume is trading obviously the
point of control is coming in at a
certain area
and then the market starts moving away
from that area right in a sense it
rejects that area and it's important so
again you know there is a swing filter
that's by default enabled on there um to
disable it you could simply uh click uh
there to make it disabled and again you
know swing filter is linked up here to
the global setting of Swing filter um
the default is five you know which is
good enough for most Traders again you
know depending on the market that you're
looking at maybe you want to adjust it
uh a little bit shorter or maybe a
little bit longer but five is a good um
a good starting point so then you just
hit uh apply and you're going to see it
appear on your chart
okay so what am I looking I got a euro
currency here today with CPI but you can
see here right there's your reversal
here short red long blue right there's
another long right here one here one
there um you know today again you know
today with CPI that's why we got that
big uh that big spike up you know I'd
love to say well you know some people
unscrupulous Str will say well look yeah
you got the signal here and then you got
that big run up but again you know
you're not going to I don't advocate for
trading right ahead of the CPI number um
you know but you can see here you know
even in the night session or early
morning 4:00 a.m. Chicago time uh you're
getting some moves there um you know
just going back to the previous day you
know there was a nice long here up to
that short and again you know if you're
trading a reversal okay I can't stress
this enough because sometimes um you
know I get emails from from Traders
saying oh you know what I I took this
short here then Market went up and and
stopped me out well if you're trading a
reversal well okay one you have the
order flow in your favor okay because
you have the in this case the PC tool
indicating that hey you know what
there's a potential reversal here you
need the follow through right the next
Bar's got to start trading down or if
it's a bullish reversal the next bar has
to start trading up right because just
because you have the order
flow conducive in the sense of it's a
bullish sign or a bearish sign you still
need that follow through okay because if
you're looking at it you know especially
on on a Time based chart you know that
you know the Market's trading you know
within that time period this is a one
minute chart after 60 seconds Boom the
bar ends okay
but when the next Bar opens you want to
see that continuation okay and again you
know if you're trading some of the more
volatile markets you know gold for
example um
you know using the the look back filter
of five might be good enough you know
here was a nice bullish signal down here
there was a nice bearish signal here um
again you you could make the the look
back longer you could make it shorter um
you know here's one that just went side
then is that CPI number um you know just
you know you can see even here you know
6 in the morning um some signals
now equities okay you know the equity
markets nowadays are going berserk um
you know every day it's tar you know
Trump anounces tariffs I mean I don't
understand why every day Trump opens his
mouth about tariffs the market goes
berserk he's been talking about this for
months but nevertheless um you know if
you're looking at some of these
uh Equity Futures you I'll start with
Dao um you know for me I think if you're
going to trade you should trade markets
that aren't as uh going to give give you
a big heart attack um you know here you
can see you know here's a a signal here
but you know these bars are are are
quite massive these are almost 100 Point
bars which is very big you know this is
on on a one minute chart how can you get
around it well if you're trading say a
range based chart problem is the
Market's going to move very fast on a
range based chart um but again you know
you can get some decent moves imagine
you shorted this one here from you know
after this bar closes next bar starts
trading down you know we'll just call
690 all the way down to you know the
400s where you get a bullish signal down
here um you know say you cover it here
490 that's a 200 Point move um but again
you know that that's on a one minute
chart honestly I think I mean for me
personally if I was going to look at
equities I'd be on a shorter range chart
you know a
uh um 30 second chart you know generally
speaking you're most likely going to get
a lot of the similar signals but to me
it's just a little bit manageable
instead of looking at bars that move 100
points um you know it's a little bit
more manageable you know and again you
know even though you got a bullish
signal here the next bar has zero follow
through so that's not a trade that you
um would be looking to take you know um
you question I get a lot is what about M
andq well honestly I think unless you
got Deep Pockets and a good Constitution
stay out of M andq but let's pull up an
M andq chart and take a
look you know to be honest I mean there
there's I 40 decent Futures markets out
there Beyond M andq Mees ym um that
don't have that sort of volatility but
again I'm not telling you don't trade it
if you're glutton for punishment which
apparently some Traders are by all means
trade it but you I just want to show you
here you know probably M andq there a
lot of movements that's why it's taking
a little bit of time for this chart to
uh to come up and again I'm looking at
a 30 second chart okay you know a one
minute chart on M andq is going to
be in my opinion um I said unless you
got
a big risk window it's not something
you're going to want to trade right but
again you know I don't want to be
telling people don't do this don't do
that if if you're able to make it work
for yourself by all means you can see
right here there was a nice bearish
signal up here again this is a 30second
chart but on this 30 second chart you're
talking about a move from you know we'll
just call it roughly here
690 down to
590 okay these are big moves in M
andq um you know if there's any bullish
signals here you know before the cash
open small ones here bullish one here
bearish one there that's right ahead of
the cash again couple minutes before
about 7 minutes before the cash open a
bullish signal another one right on the
cash open bearish one here but again
this next bar didn't go lower so again
you even though you have the PC shadow
the bearish PC shadow the next bar has
to start trading down if it's bearish
just as if it's bullish the next bar has
to be trading higher than the high of
the bar with the signal okay to me
that's just basic you know you want to
be trading in the direction of the
market not going against the direction
of the
market right that's the whole point of
orderflow right quote trading on the
side of the institutions well if you're
getting short but nobody else is getting
short why why would you want to be short
okay um so you know again that's the uh
that's the new tool one of the new tools
we've got a lot of new tools on order
flows Trader 8 but this is one that I
you know is is dear to me I I did uh
earlier this year you know we I did a
special training workshop
on um you know some
setups so you know people that attended
that Workshop were were aware of the
setup um you know long before we even
added it into uh orderflows Trader
8 okay so anyway guys um thanks for
watching this video and I'll see you
guys on the next video take care